[موسيقى]
بصفتنا Madame Tuso، نحاول دائمًا تقديم
تلك التجربة التفاعلية حيث
يمكن لضيوفنا المشاركة والتفاعل
وخلق تلك اللحظة الممتعة والذاكرة المطلقة،
لقد لاحظنا أن الكثير من ضيوفنا
يحبون التظاهر بأنهم شخصية vax
ويقفون مثل  تقوم شخصية vax
بوضعية معينة ولهذا السبب توصلنا
إلى أفكار المقالب التي
نقدمها في مناطق مختلفة داخل منطقة
الجذب uh الدعائم والملابس حيث
يمكن لزوارنا وضيوفنا استخدامها ومقلب
عائلاتهم وأصدقائهم الذين تعرفهم قادمين
إلى Madame  يحب الكثير من الضيوف
التقاط مقاطع فيديو يحبون
التقاط الصور وإنشاء
محتويات مثيرة وتلك الذكريات التي
ستدوم معهم
[موسيقى]
مدى الحياة في الوقت الحالي، نقدم ثلاث
دعائم ومناطق مزحة مختلفة في منطقة
الجذب، وهي واحدة من أكثر المناطق جذبًا  المناطق الأكثر شعبية
هي العرض الذي نقدمه مع
الملكة مع صاحبة الجلالة إليزابيث الثانية بحيث
يكون للضيوف خيار استخدام
الدعائم التي يمكنك في الأساس
ارتداء ملابسها كواحدة من آلهة الملكة
والتصوير كونها واحدة من أكثر
المناطق شعبية لدينا  حيث يمكنك
ترك فيلمك الخيالي النهائي،
لدينا كرسي المخرج الخاص بنا حيث يمكنك
ارتداء ملابس المخرج والتظاهر بأنك
تقوم أساسًا بإخراج فيلم
لـ Tom Cruz أو V Diesel ثم قم
بمزاح أصدقاء عائلتك
[موسيقى] مرة أخرى